vous y travaillez avec ma maman un
restaurant en cuisine quand il
travaillait je regardais un petit peu ce
qu'elle faisait et cuisiner pour nom
pour ses enfants
et puis après j'ai pris goût et mais
j'étais curieuse d'aller voir ce qui se
passe et jd beaucoup des gens quand ils
avaient des réceptions ou aux aider en
cuisine et j'ai vraiment appris de moi
même en lisant beaucoup aussi en faisant
des oies sept ans les histoires et en
commençant bien souvent j'aime la
cuisine créole
je sais que nous avons du monde de bons
produits
alors j'ai dit je vais faire la cuisine
de mon pays en améliorant un petit peu
offert un petit peu plus frugaux mai
mais tout en ayant de la saveur il faut
des légumes verts on dit cinq fruits et
légumes par jour mais je met vraiment
l'accent sur nos légumes verte
je fais beaucoup de légumes vapeur c'est
à dire du poireau des navets de
l'aubergine des gombos beaucoup des
épinards du pays
et vu les légumes patate banane jeunes
ignames dachine puis je fais mon marché
tous les jours parce que ce ne sont pas
les mêmes
marchand et pour avoir vraiment dû de la
fraîcheur
j'aimais marchande qui sont des
marchands de la campagne je sais que
c'est des petits producteurs qui ne
travaille pas trop avec des produits
chimiques ou bien dit des engrais de
pury dion
ce sont des gens qui font leur petit
jardin ce sont des petits jardins
créoles